boa tarde para ele a inovação não é
invenção e inovação é quando uma
invenção tem impacto na vida das pessoas
dez anos atrás até muito mais do que
isso dez anos atrás foi a inauguração
piraí demonstrou que tecnologia um
catalisador do desenvolvimento econômico
e social
minha palestra hoje não é uma celebração
do passado é uma visão de futuro o que
vai ser o seu piraí digital 3.0 essa é a
pergunta que coloco pra vocês e pra nós
com uma coletividade definir isso aqui
mas antes de falar do 3.0 vou falar um
pouquinho de 1.0 e foi o momento da
democratização da conectividade
esse é o momento final dos anos 90 o
debate era inclusão digital
o digital onde vai muita gente
conversando sobre isso irá e se
encontrou num momento em que 70% dos
empregos da cidade e desaparecer do dia
para a noite e que a cidade decidiu
fazer quando decidiu fazer implementaram
correram atrás lutaram pediram e
conseguiram ser a primeira cidade
brasileira com 100% de conectividade
esse é uma foto muito bacana que eu
achei mostra a vida na cidade de piraí
com a tecnologia não atrapalhando mas
simplesmente agregando iraí na verdade
estava num momento muito interessante
muito na frente da curva hoje é um
relatório da onu que mostra que todos os
países em azul já tem um programa
nacional de banda larga com direitos
sociais associados
então rio piraí fez não foi apenas
conectar mas foi conectar e trazer
direitos sociais com uma base digital
esse ano é um ano muito importante
serão 7 bilhões com b de conexões à
internet
nós estamos manteremos mais conexões à
internet do que nós temos seres humanos
e o que é mais bacana nisso tudo é que
nós teremos mais conexões em países em
desenvolvimento do que nos países
desenvolvidos
então isso demonstra que piraí dez anos
atrás
a visão de que isso é fundamental não só
para o país mas para um país em
desenvolvimento
piraí digital 2.0
então olhando do ponto de vista de
cidadania digital a cidade olhou essa
infraestrutura e foi o que nós vamos
fazer não fazer uma coisa diferente é
mas eu explicar deixa o pessoal que
tocou esse programa explicar para vocês
falam primeiro vídeo
quando a gente falou à rede e se em 2003
2004 todas as escolas tinham seu
laboratório
mas aí ela querendo um pouco além e
surgiu essa possibilidade do governo
federal de fazer de ter aí um projeto
piloto luca um computador por aluno
desde 2007 pioneiros com apoio da intel
nec nós trabalhamos com clemente
hoje temos a ampliação desse projeto em
toda rede nas 21 escolas de piraí com
6.200 alunos dois anos nós atingindo
meta de 15 anos do ministério da
educação no ideb a escola de arrozal
ela tinha o índice de desenvolvimento da
educação básica e pedido pelo ministério
da educação
muito baixo ea implantação do que na
escola alcançou o ideb de 4.4 saiu do
ideb de 2.4 realmente foi assim uma um
resultado surpreendente não só o ideb a
evasão escolar problemas de disciplina
dentro de sala de aula e depois o
clemente o aluno que interessa e fica
mais curioso ele fica mais confiante
grado os espaços educacionais se
multiplica
eu quero uma turma com oito computadores
e posso caminhar pela cidade caminha
pela própria escola e um museu a casa da
cultura e trabalhar uma aula venda da
casa da cultura então eu tenho
possibilidade de pensar uma cidade
educadora uma cidade criativa e vídeo é
um vídeo muito longo tem vários
depoimentos e vocês viram o depoimento
das pessoas que foram os líderes que
organizaram e fizeram isso acontecer mas
acho mais importante a gente vê quem foi
atingido por isso queria convidar até o
palco a thaísa que é uma aluna do 1º na
primeira geração do do programa
conhecimento em piraí
8 thaisa mora na zona rural de piraí
hoje para chegar aqui e levou uma hora e
eu queria perguntar thaísa como é que
foi com esse programa influenciou sua
vida o que mudou então todo o
conhecimento que adquiri com os projetos
no colégio eu podia passar pra minha
família como você disse mora na zona
rural
meus pais não têm esse contato com a
realidade tecnologia então eu peguei um
pouco de sutura e passei pra minha
família muito bacana quer dizer são
consequência de um programa como esse às
vezes não intencionais você tem inclusão
digital trazendo toda a família é uma
coisa bacana não planejada mas que é uma
consequência disso e agora como é que
vai ser o seu futuro que está planejando
cinco mais ou menos quanto tempo sem os
quatro anos em que você participou qual
é o seu futuro agora quem está
planejando então meu foco é medicina
pretendo me formar em medicina maravilha
eo piraí digital a pergunta que eu
pergunto eu diria que nós vamos fazer o
que falta o que você queria fazer assim
no futuro para piraí então que abrange
as demais localidades que atinja mais
pontos mais gente então quer dizer um
programa efetivo iria agradecer a thaísa
uma passada de palmas pra ela
obrigada isso é uma inovação
a invenção com impacto na vida das
pessoas
essa é a missão da intel no mundo muita
gente pensa então vou comprar um
computador ou comprar um notebook a
nossa missão é melhorar a vida das
pessoas através da tecnologia
vamos falar um pouquinho de piraí 3.0
que até minha provocação que eu quero
chegar logo nela mas olha só essa foto é
o foto famosa mas o que é mais famoso
pra mim é o seguinte esse caso de piraí
se transformar uma referência global
esse caso foi apresentado no ted global
em na escócia e o que eu vejo aqui cada
um desses são programas cada uma dessas
fotos é um programa diferente e se
espelhou no que foi feito aqui hoje 15
milhões de estudantes são atingidos por
programas similares não foi feito
pioneiramente em piraí
o impacto tremendo inovação local
brasileira esse projeto foi feito pela
intel do brasil aqui no brasil
comandando a rede global de inovação da
intel
vocês vêm aí as diferentes a etnias
atingidos pelo programa um problema
tremendo orgulho para nós mas isso
acabou
eu acho que não vamos falar um segundo
vídeo enquanto vai passando esse vídeo
comentando algumas coisas tudo que vocês
vão ver nesse vídeo implementável hoje a
tecnologia existe inovação fai a gente
precisa agora implementar isso na vida
das pessoas
o que eu noto nesse vídeo que o
professor ele deixa de ser um
palestrante e ele passasse um formador
ele trabalha com os alunos e intervém no
momento apropriado ele deixa descoberta
acontecer o aprendizado acontece através
de execução tanque tem um desafio como é
que a gente faz uma ponte melhor que
vocês vão ver esses meninos implementar
isso muita gente tem uma dúvida será que
o melhor computador por aluno é um
tablet ou é um notebook vocês vão ver
esse vídeo que os dois estavam antes
especiais ele se converte em thaísa
comentou
a tecnologia chega em casa e interação
com a família é parte do processo
educacional educação não acontece apenas
na sala de aula conforme os alunos vão
fazendo progresso eles vão sendo
acompanhados do jeito que está para trás
é acompanhado pelo professor o sujeito
que tá pra frente como essa menina ela
já começa a falar com o engenheiro de
pontos que ela já cumpriu aquela carga
no final vocês vão ver uma impressora
tridimensional em que eles têm uma
solução eles têm uma idéia e eles vão
acabar implementando isso fisicamente
essa impressora existe ela custa 150
dólares para ser construída foi
apresentado no hotel ligou na escócia
também
hum
11 11
essa impressora qualquer escola no
brasil tem condição de ter uma dessas e
agora é o momento será que só deu certo
ou não vai dar chabu vai quebrar minha
ponte em outra escola não deu muito
certo
há 15 anos no futuro esses meninos vão
lembrar dessa alta mas a gente fala
muito de educação e até me emociono com
fotos e professora vez um negócio desse
todo mês mas o em frente olhando para o
que aconteceu aqui dez anos atrás
você vê que a piraí surfou uma onda ele
percebeu uma inflexão tecnológica e
antes de que aquilo fosse óbvio agiram
nós temos a internet das coisas grande
próxima inflexão são 14 trilhões de
impacto na economia 26 bilhões de
dispositivos 26 bi são três dispositivos
conectados por ser humano na face da
terra
agora o que é esse monstro da internet
das coisas
a gente está usando isso não é verdade a
internet das coisas é muito simples são
máquinas falando com máquinas através da
internet quando você vai no caixa
eletrônico tiram dinheiro aquele número
aparece magicamente no saldo da conta
por que por que essa máquina que é um pc
disfarçado de caixa eletrônico
transferir se transferir cidade para a
nuvem
agora o que a nuvem a nuvem esse
mistério da nuvem bom sinto informar que
eu não venha isso aí
a nuvem é um monte de computadores que
parecem umas geladeiras
então em algum prédio aí pelo mundo o
problema é que ninguém sabe onde é que
esse prédio então quando a gente faz o
slide a gente faz ele é sempre uma nuvem
ele agora a internet das coisas na
internet que conecta mais do que as
pessoas hoje a gente já tem uma grande
fração da população conectada no mundo
28 por cento dos domicílios no brasil 34
e 69% dos brasileiros estão conectados
de alguma forma na internet às vezes nem
há uma conexão pessoal através de
família emprego o tio que tem mas as
pesquisas mostram isso
o próximo passo a próxima onda são as
coisas se conectarem estão vendo ali
veículos robôs
será que isso é uma coisa muito assim
o futuro fora do do propósito não no rio
de janeiro a intel com a petrobras e
implementou o primeiro posto de gasolina
do futuro
esse é um posto de gasolina em que o
veículo entra sensores no veículo a
comunicam com as máquinas o que o
veículo é abastecido é lavado ele parte
e nenhum cartão de crédito é trocado no
processo a isso aumentar a fidelização
nível de serviço quando você entra num
posto de gasolina como esse ele sabe se
você é vegetariano então você entrou na
loja de conveniência não vai vender
cachorro quente pra você e que nós
fizemos em cada uma dessas certa tem um
processador capacidade computacional no
poste na máquina no dentro da loja de
conveniência para gerar algumas
experiências diferentes
eu vou correr um pouquinho aqui porque
eu também que o tempo apertado
experiência de varejo o varejo digital
como é que eu faço o estoque hoje em dia
uma farmácia tem muito pouco estoque
porque porque o caixa da farmácia em
forma cada vez que um medicamento é
vendido não precisa de capital empatado
em estoque
isso mudou várias mudanças na
adversidade é uma máquina que tem um
display ali ela tem mais variedade de
drinques do que é capaz de você colocar
uma janelinha
agora se eu tenho um tag em cada um dos
veículos
imagina uma placa eletrônica eu consigo
a gerar um sistema de transporte
inteligente no qual o pedágio acontece
sem que você tenha que parar mais
importante o qual se consiga desenhar no
mapa uma região do mapim que esse
veículo pode operar quando ele sair dali
ele manda um sms através da internet das
coisas posso decidir desliga a injeção
eletrônica nesse veículo mas não é papai
noel do pa nova iguaçu hoje todos esses
serviços que eu não vou cobrir passam a
ser possíveis quando você tem o seu
veículo conectado à internet para a
saúde
a gente tem aqui uma oportunidade ímpar
quantas vezes na frente aqui na frente
quantas vezes você foi num hospital e
eles perguntam se é alérgico a alguma
coisa aí entra outra pessoa você levo
alguma coisa eu já respondi à pergunta
eles deveriam saber isso desde que eu
nasci
aliás foi esse hospital que descobriu
que ele era alérgico a gatos
é um absurdo isso agora que eu tenho
aqui eu tenho uma identidade universal
que pode ser biométrica eu posso olhar
uma câmera
os olhos ou pode ser um dispositivo um
cartão a eu tenho um prontuário único em
que ali se armazena todos os dados desde
o berço até o fim da vida
imagens médicas raio-x diagnósticos
agora eu fui ontem matou hoje se o
sujeito descobriu que eu sou alérgico e
agora estou com um problema de ortopedia
o cara vai me dar uma injeção aquela
análise de dados passa a ser possível o
sistema na frente do médico vai informar
tudo aquilo olha cuidado não defini se
lina no fla-flu 80 ele teve um problema
há dez anos atrás com isso a análise
aumenta a eficiência - tempo perdido com
perguntas redundantes sem falar às
pessoas que morrem no sistema porque ao
invés de receber suco de laranja com
aveia recebeu o suco de laranja na veia
porque a caligrafia do médico é uma
coisa em geral e feliz
essa é uma oportunidade muito grande
você imagina o tamanho do banco de dados
desse prontuário único com imagens de
ressonância magnética grandes volumes de
dados e que coisa bacana que a gente
pode implementar aqui quem sabe o que é
isso que mudando de tema internet das
coisas
isso é uma máquina brasileira que ela é
utilizada para aplicar fertilizantes e
pesticidas
então todo mundo pensa no agricultor a
equipe ainda tem muita gente agricultor
até a família thaísa na zona rural gente
imagina um sujeito com uma enxada o
brasil é o quarto maior exportador de
produto agropecuário do mundo e nós
somos referência tecnológica nisso essa
máquina inventada aqui
agora o que falta nessa inter nessa
máquina que ela se conecta à internet
pra quê
porque eu conheço a história desse solo
dois anos atrás eu apliquei certos
nutrientes eu sei que se encontram ali
eu conheci entender o espaçamento de
semente que aplique no ano anterior e
hoje em dia as máquinas sem precisão pra
pegar uma moeda você joga no meio desse
campo essa máquina dirigi la sozinha
você tem precisão não de metro mais de
um centímetro com essa precisão e com
esse banco de dados enorme é possível e
é muito importante você ter uma
agricultura de precisão na internet das
coisas
o brasil já é líder nesse brasil tem que
deixar de ter vergonha de ser líder em
agricultura porque é uma coisa
maravilhosa que a gente tem e nós temos
condição de ser líderes em agricultura
para digital
é aquela imagem do jeca tatu com a com a
enxada é uma coisa tão antiga quanto a
maria fumaça e não existe mais isso aqui
é uma outra oportunidade será que piraí
vai ser a primeira comunidade com
agricultura digital implementada será
que ela ir aí vai sempre vai implementar
pela primeira vez essa visão de educação
completa que a gente continuamente vai
evoluindo em parceria com o governo
o comércio digital saúde digital vamos
colocar todos os cidadãos de piraí com o
prontuário eletrônico essa provocação
que eu falei que ia fazer pra vocês eu
não tenho resposta
mesmo porque sozinho ninguém faz nada e
onde é que nós nos encontramos
procurei uma imagem e representasse esse
momento de piraí e do brasil estão
engatinhando
dez anos se passaram dez anos a história
de uma de uma nação não é nada eu acho
que as oportunidades que nós temos aqui
para implementar não só em piraí no rio
de janeiro no brasil são impressionantes
obrigado